this is Thursday November 3rd five days
until the 2016 presidential election and
this is the closer it is not breaking
news he will do it again
today at least once Donald Trump will
attack the media did it in Miami
yesterday said quote another important
issue for Americans is integrity in
journalism these people are among the
most dishonest people I've ever met
spoken to done business with these are
the most dishonest people the crowd
booed lustily there has never been
anywhere near the media dishonesty like
we've seen in this election don't worry
they won't spin the cameras and show the
kinds of massive crowds they won't do
that he says this every single day
yesterday he singled out for the third
time one reporter my ex-girlfriend
incidentally Katy tur from NBC still a
dear friend she was Harris by the
simpering bullies who populate the Trump
crowds but she is fine because unlike
them or Trump she's neither a coward nor
a fascist still abusing the media
encouraging the incitement of physical
harm against them that always whips up a
Trump crowd but it's also a preview his
son-in-law Jared Kushner was rumored
this week to be using personnel
recruiters to try to snap up Trump TV
which starts the obvious cognitive
dissonance thing echoing again Trump TV
means his family expects him to lose the
election right already in the proverbial
soft launch on Facebook it is a cynical
exploitation of the last 16 months of
relentless Trump's self-promotion and
reality show plot lines and Network
enablers and the accumulation of a
database of at least 12 million email
addresses but it is based on that one
premise president Trump would have no
time for his own political television
apparatus right
what would a President of the United
States need his own television network
for but what would a President of the
United States elected purely as a cult
figure and facing enormous opposition
from the very moment of his inauguration
do with his own television network
what would a President of the United
States with no apparent commitment to
nor understanding of democracy with
only a stated insistence that quote I
alone can fix it
what would he put on his own television
network Trump TV is not designed as a
fallback in case he loses Trump TV is
designed as a ready-made propaganda
outlet in case he wins Trump TV is not a
consolation prize it is a means of
consolidating power once he is in the
White House it might not even remain
Trump TV it might morph into something
like official state TV what more could
he ask for indeed what would he need
more than a media outlet that always
agrees with his in decisions and his
whims and his insults and then demonizes
and then organizes action against those
who criticize him and ultimately can be
amped up to out shout the unofficial
American broadcasters the disloyal ones
like CBS and NBC and ABC and CNN and Fox
News and every nascent operation from
the closer to Breitbart TV if they will
not tow the line hell why bother out
shouting them for very long
Trump has already threatened to all the
media of this country all those
protected by libel laws all free speech
he is threatened CNN and the New York
Times by name nine days ago his henchmen
dance Camino threatened megyn kelly
watch he tweeted what happens to her
after this election is over why would
you assume Trump would bother sticking
to the laws when he believes as no
president in our history has ever
believed that he can just nullify laws
with executive orders why not cut to the
chase and just announce that you can't
broadcast news without a license from
the American government and we will let
you know when your license application
has been reviewed in the age of
satellites and Internet it is doubtful
that Trump TV as state TV could totally
drown out outside voices even when the
Nazis took over all of German radio in
1934 and then in 1939 they made it a
criminal offense to listen to foreign
stations words of dissent did make it
through but not from within their
country and asked the Chinese or the
North Koreans how unfettered their
internet is
they are told and eventually most of
them come to actually believe that in
blocking them from seeing half or more
of all websites their governments aren't
denying them truth but protecting them
from external brainwashing happily that
could never happen here not with Trump
having demonized the current American
media during virtually every one of his
speeches like yesterday to the point
where on the 13th the last month at
Cincinnati the motorcade serving the
entire traveling campaign corps had to
be guarded by police dressed in riot
gear happily that could never happen
here not with Trump having advocated for
restrictions on the Internet to keep
terrorists from communicating or from
brainwashing American minds and then he
would decide who's a terrorist happily
that could never happen here not with
Trump's toady Newt Gingrich having gone
on record as long ago as 2006 saying
that part of the internet needed to be
turned off and part of the First
Amendment needed to be reconsidered no
no no Trump TV is his back-up plan just
to cash in on his indisputable
popularity with the average American the
average American who believes what Trump
tells him that the rig media is
conspiring against him and conspiring
against Trump who shouts lugan press and
yells homophobic and racist slurs at the
reporters and does so with impunity who
wants to hear that Trump is right and
Trump is good and Trump is winning and
Trump has gotten them all better jobs
and Trump has made America great again
and Trump has gotten rid of those filthy
immigrants and Trump is happy to raise
the chocolate ration to 20 grams a week
and Trump has killed two terrorists and
Trump alone fixed it and Trump
recognizes which group is the next
threat and Trump is acting to protect
you from it and Trump has good news
about the fighting and Trump is right we
have always been at war with Eastasia
but no Trump TV is just his back-up plan
if he loses besides even if he is
elected and even if he wanted to do this
he couldn't you know establish his own
Trump TV network and then shut down all
the other media in this country let me
ask you one question who would stop him
that's the closer i'm keith olbermann
watch this space